well this is long overdue
but better late than never
uh in this video i want to share my
round 9 game from the battle of the
sexes tournament in gibraltar i played
grand master zansaya abdul abdulmalik
from kazakhstan and we had a really
crazy
tactical battle it was a cool opening a
kind of rare opening that i've never
played before
and then middle game was insane
i'm still trying to wrap my mind around
what happened in this game
so
before we jump into it i do want to
thank the sponsor of today's video
which is no one unfortunately
but i do want to let you guys know that
i have two other
active youtube channels
which
maybe some people don't know about
i have a eric rosen extra channel which
i've been posting full streams to when i
stream on twitch not every twitch stream
makes it
to my main channel but uh i'm posting
three new streams per week to this
channel
and i also have a clips channel so if
you have a shorter attention span
you can watch some shorter form content
so without out of the way let's get into
this game and zancia played pawn e4
and this was actually my
third time
encountering e4 in the gibraltar
tournament
uh first round i played uh iframski uh
marcel who
uh also played e4 went into a bishop b5
czech sicilian and then i played
music who went into this position uh
maria music
but uh after i played knight f6 she
played bishop e5
so i didn't have a main line open
sicilian
until this game
uh i played the move knight f6 and uh
it's a somewhat offbeat move i explained
this in the the music video which you
can watch i'll try and link it somewhere
maybe down below
but uh the point is to provoke knight c3
which sansaya did play in this game
and then i take on uh on d4 so we did
get into a mainline open sicilian
position
and from here i played
g6 going into a dragon and i will say
i've never played the a dragon before in
my life in a uh a serious tournament
game
so this was a little bit new for me but
uh i spent a good amount of time before
the tournament preparing uh
some interesting lines
and what we're going to see is i don't
enter a traditional dragon in the sense
that
i deviate from main theory pretty early
as early as move seven
uh in this position the main move by far
is casting kingside for black
but i play the third most popular move
which is pawn a6 and we can call this a
dragon dwarf or some people say dragdorf
where i'm combining ideas in the dragon
and then nardorf nardorf is another very
common variation of sicilian where black
plays in early asics to stay flexible
and one of the reasons for playing this
move is i delay counseling and after
white plays most common move queen d2
i play
another kind of funky looking move i
commit to knock housing king's side but
rather play
pawn to h5
and this move just looks really random
if if you've never seen this before
but the point is it's prophylactic i'm
preventing the bishop from coming to h6
i'm also accidentally enabling capslock
because i'm still getting used to this
keyboard but
white can no longer go for this uh
this kind of common middle game idea to
trade off
my dragon bishop because i control h6
square it's a bit harder for white to
attack i'm also preventing light from
expanding quickly with pawn g4 and this
move is one of the top suggestions
from leela chess which is of course
one of the newer stronger chess engines
that's based off a neural network has a
more kind of human style approach
and uh i think even stockfish has h5 as
one of the top moves like within the top
three moves
so it uh it's definitely
not as popular as the main lines but it
is becoming more trendy and magnus
carlson actually played this as black
uh not too long ago against grieshook
they played the game in 2020 that also
had this position
now in that game grisha played bishop's
e4 but in this game
zansaya castle queenside
and
after castling queenside it guarantees a
game is gonna get sharp pretty quickly i
continue here pawn b5 king b1 bishop b7
so completing development and she plays
pawn h4
and during the game i'm pretty sure pawn
h4 was a surprise for me i was more
prepared for a line like bishop e2
and i had a hard time understanding the
purpose of pawn h4
um but maybe it was just an attempt to
prevent me from playing h4 maybe it's a
secure control over the g5 square
it's a move that's playable doesn't
really change too much in the position
and i do want to mention one alternative
that actually after i
i played bishop to b7
i i was thinking could be a potentially
funny line
that uh i'm curious if she had
considered during the game but it turns
out white could play the move pawn e5
here which is actually a very forcing
move i would have to take the pawn
and then there's a really funny move
knight to e6
which
just looks ridiculous on the surface but
this is playable because i can't take
the knight right away due to queen takes
t8 and
then i would
have to say oh no my queen
but after queen takes d2
white has an intermediate move knight
takes g7 check
king would have to move to f8 and then
white has another kind of in-between
move
still delaying recapturing the queen 96
check
and this would force me to accept triple
pawns
but after rook takes d2
uh this position is actually really
playable for black i had calculated this
a little bit uh while it was her move
where it was still possible we could go
into this and i'd seen the move knight
d5 and
even though it looks like the pawns are
weak
black does have some nice pressure in
the center and it's hard for white to
actually exploit the
triple e pawns in the center
and on top of that black is up a pawn so
i wouldn't be too concerned with
entering this position
so going back
uh we did not enter the the funny line
she plays h4
and the next few moves were just
improving moves for both of us knight d7
a3 discouraging b4
queen c7 bishop e2
rook b8
and uh and then she plays rook c1 so
we're both kind of just staying within
our own territory they're reorganizing
some of uh some of our furniture
and what she did was she uh basically
shifted her king
and rook over
to one square so it actually looks like
she castled illegally but uh from
white's perspective maybe it was worth
doing this because the king is a little
bit safer just tucked away and
with the rook on c1 she does have some
long-term pressure against my queen
and as we're going to see one of white's
plans is to
move the knight away from c3 uh on
knight a2 and then potentially go for
the idea of pawn c4 to
open the c file and target my queen so
kind of a long term move
um now the move i played here was also
trying to
use some x-ray vision in the position
given my rook is aligned with white's
king
i played the move bishop to a8 just
clearing the path um maybe intending to
play b4 next move but she very promptly
prevented this with knight a2
and now it's clear that white does have
some ideas of c4 maybe also combined
with knight b4
and i realized after this move that i
have a really thematic central break
that usually when the knight is on c3
the move that i want to play just isn't
possible at being pawn d5 but here pawn
d5
looked really nice and i went ahead and
played it just because it is well
supported and e4 is less supported from
light so now i have three
attackers against e4 pawn
and if white takes the pawn on d5 i
would happily recapture
pressuring the bishop unleashing my
other fiend of bishop on the king's side
so i have the double fiance and this
would be a very very pleasant position
to play for black
so rather than capturing on d5 she
played the move knight to b4 which is a
counter-attack and now uh not only does
the knight pressure the d5 pawn but she
makes a strong threat of knight takes a6
which i do have to to kind of deal with
because this would be a fork
so i played the move queen d6 which
defends the pawn laterally along the
sixth rank but also reinforces d5 so
this is a nice kind of multi-purpose
centralizing move
and then she played knight to b3
so uh the tension is mounting and now
the queen uh for white is
also pressuring along the d file and
white is looking to control some of the
weaker dark squares on my queen side
and here i went ahead and finally castle
i figured that it is very much worth
getting my rook into the game and i
wasn't too concerned about bishop h6
ideas here given that
the the main focus is in the center so
she went ahead and played rook to d1
and then i played knight to b6 so aiming
to get my knight into c4 with pressure a
lot of juicy targets in white's position
and when i played this move it actually
looks like this is a blunder at first
because white has
a cool tactical idea
which
almost works but then i have an even
cooler tactical idea it looks like white
can play the move pawn e5 with
the fork and after i take the pawn
then there is a skewer bishop to f4 it
turns out in this position black has a
really really incredible move
and if you don't see it right away feel
free to pause the video and try and find
it because it is really satisfying if
you can find this move on your own
but the move is
not moving the queen but rather knight
to e4
which
just works out beautifully for black
because it's a counter attack against
white's queen but it's also a main one
threat
and black is just getting the upper hand
after whatever white plays here
um if bishop takes queen i would take
with check and then recapture
with my bishop on e5 and black has an
advantage with
just better center and being up upon
temporarily so she took a think after i
played knight b6 and
i think it was pretty clear that she had
seen
this line
if white doesn't see the prospect of
knight e4 then e5 does look very
attractive
but she went for a different aggressive
idea
bishop to c5
and here we see a different type of
skewer
along a different diagonal where my
pieces
are a little bit shish kebabbed from the
bishop
and here my queen just has to find a
square to move to
and
i realized that it's not so easy to find
a reasonable square for the queen
uh the move i wanted to play was queen
e5
uh just to get the same tactical ideas
against white's queen side
but i didn't see what to do against the
move queen g5
and uh white just has
some really annoying initiative and my
tactics are just a little bit too slow
here i was fantasizing about the line
queen digs b2 king jigs b2 knight takes
e4
but sadly uh black is just going to be
worse at the end of this after let's say
king
uh
king a2 maybe even bishop d4 is simpler
and after i regain the queen
i'm just down a piece in the end
so this would not work out
so instead of moving to e5 where the
queen is a bit more exploitable
i chose a more
exotic destination for my queen and
played the move queen h2
which on the surface looks a little bit
wild but
i do target both pawns
and i'm pretty sure this is what the
position called for
now it turns out that white has a really
nice way of securing an advantage here
which he did not find during the game
but if you turn on the engine here
sockfish will say white's winning after
the move rook to h1 and i was a little
bit worried about this during the game
because then the queen has to find a new
square and i can't take on g2 because
then the queen gets trapped so uh i'd
probably end up playing a move like
queen g3
but then white can kind of cash in on
the queen side
and black is uh is the one suffering
here
um thankfully this didn't happen and she
took on a6 immediately
and this allowed me a nice
counter-attack with knight to c4
hitting the queen
leaving my rook attacked on b8 and
i should point out here that if she
takes
i would happily take back and there's
some
some really tricky lines like if she
takes on b8 i can take back with rook
and even though i'm temporarily down the
exchange there's some really nice
pressure against both the knight and the
b2 pawn and after a move like knight d4
which looks like it it does kind of
defend everything i could retreat to c7
and there's some uh there's definitely
some nagging initiative for black
so rather than
uh taking on c4
she played the move queen to e1
and game continues from here rook bc8
saving the rook
she played queen g1
and uh i didn't want the queen trade i
wanted to keep my queen as an attacking
piece threatening maiden one
uh provoking bishop d4
then queen a6 hitting the knight
and after knight to b4
things finally begin to liquidate a
little bit in the center after takes and
takes
and uh i was feeling good at this point
given that my queen survived even though
i'm aligning uh aligned with the rook on
the d-file uh there's no great
discoveries for white and my pieces are
beginning to find some really nice
coordination
uh just with the the knight support on
c4 the bishop really nicely aligned with
the king
and white's pieces just a little bit uh
misplaced i would say
and she played the move pawn to g4 here
which is an attempt to
try and uh just burst open the king side
but it turns out g4 was a very big error
and my next move was one of my proudest
moves of the game
uh because it was basically a sneaky
double attack
and the moves uses just kind of the
whole board and some really nice
geometry i'm debating whether to tell
people to pause the video and try and
find the move for black uh if you're up
for a challenge feel free to do so but
the move i play is queen to e6 and the
reason why
this is a double attack looks like it's
just a single attack of course i am
threatening
uh the pawn in g4 now three times
but i have an even stronger threat with
this move
i'm aligning myself with the knight on
b3
which is not defended because this pawn
is pinned on c2
so it turns out my thread in this
position
is to take on a3
and then take on b3
so for example if i plays a move like g5
i can take
take and then take
and then black is just having all the
fun here
if bishop b2 knight saves itself
unleashes a bishop
and white is probably just getting mated
very soon because knight c3 is also just
a massive threat
and this is usually what happens when
your pieces just all are directed
towards opponents king
tactics just work out very beautifully
for black
so when i played queen e6
uh white's in a bit of a pickle and uh
what she ended up having to do was trade
off
the bishop for the knight on c4
and i was happy with this transformation
because i'm keeping my lights for bishop
so light squares going forward are more
likely to be in black's control and
after knight c5 i was more than happy to
just chuck my rook take the knight
sagging exchange but after knight takes
g4
i have a ton of compensation for the
exchange i do have a pawn for it but i
also have just the beautiful bishops a
really really safe king
also a four on one majority on the king
side
during the game i
i had a good feeling black was better
and stockfish does support this
assessment uh it's saying that black is
um as close to winning gives minus 2.4
here
but as we're going to see the position's
still really crazy and it's not so easy
to convert
and i was also getting somewhat low on
time
just because the middle game was so
complicated it uh every move i was
probably averaging like four or five
minutes
at least
so um
so time trouble was approaching
and the game goes on she played king to
a2
i play rook eight improving my worst
place piece now aligning with the king
she played bishop to b6
which uh
how to describe this move i think she
played bishop b6 because there's some
idea of rook d8 just to force a rook
trade
so i went ahead and played bishop to h6
hitting the rook on c1
not quite trapping the rook but forcing
it to move to just an even sadder square
and now uh now the c2 pawn looks very
juicy even though the knight is
defending it
i went ahead and played pawn c3 check
uh unleashing the queen
forcing pawn to b3 and then
uh the next move felt really really good
bishop d2 creating a really solid
formation of the pawn defending the
bishop bishop defending the pawn
and
now the rook is just completely cut off
from the entire open file
and the c2 pawn is looking really
delicious given that i have ideas of
queen f5
but she kept fighting and she played the
move bishop to c5
and the move i really wanted to play
here
was queen f5 just creating the battery
but
after rook to f1 my queen can't maintain
itself on the diagonal i'd have to
retreat
so instead i went after a different a
weak pawn in the position with the move
queen f6
targeting the h-pawn and
she still played rook f1
i snagged the pawn
and then she played queen d4
and here we're on move 36
and
this is where i was getting really low
on time
uh we were playing with a time control
that on move 40 we would each get extra
half hour
but in this situation i was already
below i want to say below three minutes
and
i began to freak out a little bit given
that my bishop
is attacked and the move that i saw and
i wanted to play was 93
but i couldn't fully
make sense of it during the game and i
was actually scared of
the move rook h1 which just leads to
complete insanity given that my bishop
could take it but my bishop is pinned to
my queen and my queen is tied down to
defend the bishop
now the engine will say box completely
winning here but it's really far from
simple
the only winning move is queen f4
and then white has a really crazy line
rook takes h5
and i'm not sure if i spotted this in
the game but i would have had to
calculate this really precisely if i
wanted to go into it because after g
takes h5
there's a funny line
rook g1 check
black's really close to then getting
mated here if this or this white has
made in one my only response is to block
with the knights
and then white has a really cool move
knight d5 hitting the queen again taking
advantage of the pin
of my bishop
also hitting the e7 pawn
um best move for black is to take and
after queen digs g5 there's a fork
and i would have had to find a really
clutch rook lift in this position
starting with the move brook a6 and
after queen takes h5
uh removing the guard of knights
attacking on it twice
uh only winning move for black rook g6
um so this would have been really
difficult to calculate from so many
moves
back
and especially given that i only had
like a couple minutes to do so
i played what i thought was a safer
option
on f5 but unfortunately when i played
this move it does leave my king a little
bit more naked
on the g8 square given that all my
kingside pawns pretty much have been
advanced
and um
[Music]
i was told after the game that
lauren's trent was going absolutely
bananas when he saw me play this move
eric rosen
for the boys
can he do quick what is this move f5
what what is this what is what is this
move
the guy is on a suicide mission
yeah
i have no words to describe this movie
he's not a chess player he's a kamikaze
pilot
[Laughter]
well this
this is just too risky look at that king
on g8 what is f5
young children watching
maybe close your eyes for the next few
moves or for the rest of the game so
after playing f5 she played queen c4
check
and then i completely freaked out i had
seen this move coming and i thought that
i can just slide over and then there's
no more checks
um the problem is that when i play king
f8
i'm aligning with a rook
and i just
walk into a pin now the f pawn is pinned
there is nothing defending the bishop
she takes the bishop
and i was sad
oh queen e4 queenie
game over blunder she just blundered the
peace
oh
oh eric oh no the bishop on a4 oh i have
to say it i just can't help it
but i kept fighting i didn't resign i
played the move rook to a5
she played queen d4
now this is my 39th move i just have
two more moves to make until getting an
extra half hour
and i blunder yet again
although the position is already lost
but i
made a really just
fatal error here played the move queen
f6
and she
cashes in even more queen d8 hitting my
king hitting my rook
and then i was even more sad
um but i didn't resign because i was
also a little bit tilted
uh played king f7
she took
and then i played on for
10 more moves despite being down
a grand total of two rooks for
two pawns i thought maybe there's still
some hope like if this was bullet
or maybe ultra bullet there would be
some hope of uh just pushing all the
pawns towards promotion so i'll just
zoom through the next several moves and
we'll see how this game finishes
queen e5 queen a7 winnie 4
not really attacking anything because
everything is defended in white's
position
she plays queen d7
and after i make one last attempt to
push some pawns
she just simplifies or takes d2
very uh
very stable move
and i i do get the pawn to the second
rank but after queen d5
we trade queens i play e5
then she plays a4 after king e6
pawn c4
it's very clear that white's past pawn
just the a-pawn really it's gonna be
more
more effective than my four connected
pass pawns
and i resigned in this position
um so it was really a
really interesting game really painful
game given that i just kind of threw
away my advantage in the span of a
couple moves with first playing f5
and then playing uh dreadful king to f8
um it turns out black is still better
here if i play the move king to g7 and
then hide the king on h6
there's still a 1.5 advantage for black
according to stockfish in this position
but um i think it was a very instructive
game and uh
kind of goes to show what i need to work
on if i want to win games like this i
have to manage my time better i have to
just
see tactics more clearly especially in
very
crazy and complicated positions and i
really have to just watch out for
opponent's simple threats
and simple tactical ideas
sometimes it can be easy to
uh to look for tactics for yourself but
it's so important to also be aware of
the opponent's ideas to just minimize
blunders
so i really hope that uh those watching
got some value out of this game
um maybe i can inspire some people to
play this uh tricky line of the the
dragon dragon dwarf sicilian
and if you have any feedback let me know
in the comments
and
i have one more recap to do from the
gibraltar battle of the sexes
so stay tuned be sure to subscribe check
out my other youtube channels
and i'll see you in the next video
goodbye